how do we calculate the kai Square test
let's go through that with an example
the Ki Square test is a hypothesis test
that is used when you want to determine
if there is a relationship between two
categorical variables we would like to
investigate whether gender has an
influence on the preferred newspaper so
our question is is there a relationship
between gender and the preferred
newspaper our null hypothesis is there
is no relationship between gender and
the preferred newspaper and our
alternative hypothesis is there is a
relationship between gender and the
preferred newspaper so first we create a
questionnaire that asks about gender and
the preferred newspaper we will then
send out the questionnaire the results
of the survey are displayed in a table
in this table we see one respondent in
each row
the first respondent is male and stated
New York Post the second respondent is
female and stated USA Today We can now
copy this table into a statistic
software like data deab data dab then
gives us the so-called contingency table
in this table you can see the variable
newspaper and the variable gender the
number of times each combination occurs
is Plott in the sales for example in
this survey There are 16 people who
stated New York Post and mail or 13
people who stated female and New York
Post now we want to know if gender has
an influence on the preferred newspaper
or put in another way is there a
relationship between gender and the
preferred newspaper now to answer this
question we use the kai Square test
there are two ways we can c calculate
the kai Square test either we use a
statistical software like data tab or we
calculate the kai Square test by hand we
start with the uncomplicated variant and
use data tab if you like you can load
the sample data set for calculation you
can find the link in the video
description to calculate a Kai Square
test online simply copy your own data
into this table or use the link to load
this data set then the variable both
gender and newspaper appear here below
now we click on hypothesis test here you
will find a variety of tests and data
tab will help you to choose the right
one for example if we click on gender
and newspaper the Ki Square test will be
automatically calculated now we get the
results for the kai Square test above we
see the contingency table for the
variables gender and newspaper the con
eny table shows us how often the
respective combinations occur in our
survey female and USA Today for example
occurs six times in the second table we
can see what the contingency table
should actually look like if the two
variables were perfectly independent
that is if gender had no influence on
the preferred newspaper here it is
important to note that all of the
frequen should be larger than five so
that the assumptions of the kai Square
test are fulfilled but this is the case
here the kai Square test now Compares
this table with that table and here we
see the results the P value is
0.91 which is much higher than our
significance level of
0.05 and therefore we keep the null
hypothesis if you don't know exactly how
how to interpret the results just click
on summary inverts a Kai Square test was
performed between gender and newspaper
all expected cell frequencies were
greater than five thus the assumptions
for the kai Square test were met there
was no statistically significant
relationship between gender and
newspaper this results in a P value of
0.918 which is above the defined
significance level of 5% the kai Square
test is therefore not significant and
the null hypothesis is not rejected if
you're unsure what exactly the P value
means just watch our video about the P
value and now we come to the question
how to calculate the kai Square test by
hand and we go through the formulas
needed don't worry it's not difficult we
need the contingency table with the obs
oberved frequencies the contingency
table with the expected frequencies that
is those frequencies that would occur
with perfectly independent variables you
can find how to calculate the expected
frequencies on data tab in the tutorial
on the kai Square test we can now
calculate the kai square with this
formula the index K stands for the
respective cell o k is the observed
frequency
e is the expected frequency so we get 6
-
6.08 squared divided by
6.08 plus the next cell 7 -
6.92 sared ided
6.92 if we do this for all cells and sum
them up we get a Kai square of 0.4
504 so this results in a Kai Square
value of
0.504 now we would like to calculate the
critical Kai Square value what do we
need it for if we use a statistical
software we simply get a P value
displayed if the value is smaller than
the significance level for example
0.05 the null hypothesis is rejected
otherwise not in our example case the
null hypothesis is not rejected by hand
however you can't really calculate the P
value therefore you read off in a table
which Kai Square value you would get
with a P value of
0.05 this Kai Square value is called the
critical Kai Square value in order to
calculate the critical Kai Square value
we need the degrees of freedom these are
obtained gain by taking the number of
rows minus one times the number of
columns minus one we have four rows and
two columns therefore we get three * 1
and thus three degrees of freedom now
let's take a look at the table of
critical Kai Square values you can find
this table on data tab the link is in
the video description we select a
significance level of Z
.05 and have three degrees of freedom
therefore our critical Kai Square value
is
7.81 15 the critical K Square value of
7.81 15 is larger than our calculated
Kai Square value of
0.504 thus the null hypothesis is
retained thanks for watching and I hope
to see you next
time